mark Stein is an author and a columnist
he joins us tonight so mark the outlines
of this are really clear Google is the
most powerful company in the history of
the world they have a chokehold on all
human information they can clearly guide
the outcome of an election if they chose
to do so they tried to influence the
last election why shouldn't we be deeply
concerned about this well we should be
deeply concerned as you said Russia
everyone goes bananas about because they
bought a hundred grands worth of
Facebook ads or whatever it was Google
is already more powerful in terms of its
control over people's lives than almost
every government on the planet and I
would say arguably it has more control
over American lives than say the
government of Russia does as a practical
matter and people are very naive about
Google searches they think that it
doesn't whether whether you're in a
hotel in Des Moines or whether you're
hanging upside down in your bondage
dungeon in Poughkeepsie when you enter
the search results everything's the same
as this lady Ileana murió has explained
they're actually capable of now
targeting election content specifically
to certain voting groups so this isn't
like you know Rock the Vote or public
attempts to get out the vote this is
where the world's most powerful company
is using data mining to channel election
in for partisan election information to
key voting demographics that's very
disturbing because they'd steal they'd
steal the election and you'd never know
it well what's so interesting to me is
the left has been very agitated for the
past six or seven years about citizens
united in the influence of money on
politics I don't think all their
concerns are stupid by the way but now
this is the or example this is the most
powerful influencer of Elections
potentially the world has ever known
and I don't think I've ever heard a
single liberal say anything about
Google's effect on elections subverting
our democracy why is that well because I
think for the old
this reason that they're doing it for as
Eliana Maria would say for our side for
our team for the left steam for
liberalism's team and that's and that's
very different in a sense there's
something quaintly old-fashioned about
the citizens you you know Jeb Bush blew
a hundred million dollars to get to 2.4
percent in Iowa the old-fashioned way by
sticking up billboards and making robo
calls and all the rest of it what if you
had a monopoly on people's access to
information and without them even
knowing about it just when they happen
to open up their phone or their laptop
in the morning you were able to direct
them to your candidate without anybody
knowing it that's that's that's far more
important that's far more scary the
implications are absolutely terrible and
this memo is absolutely terrible in what
it reveals about Google you know the
silent donation bit is very interesting
because as you say it has legal
implications whatever legal implications
they are they're a lot more solid than
whether some guys paid off some porn
star just to take a random example I
I hope our elected officials pay
attention to this mark well so we'll see
you later in the show thank you very
much